[Music]
i'm gabriela and this is my dad mike
i'm mike and this is my daughter my name
is benjamin and this is my beautiful
daughter
uh my name is sigali and my dad is
benjamin hi i'm rihanna this is my dad
brian
hi i'm brian this is my daughter bruh we
get it
yeah i had to skip it i'm sorry step
forward if you agree with the statement
daughters must be raised differently
than sons
uh yes okay benjamin
so the way you insert a tampon there's
going to be different life there's going
to be
different risks different situations
that they're going to have to deal with
so yeah do you raise them differently
yes
just because the world sees them
differently i have to
accustom them to how the world is going
to see them
yeah yeah they have to i'm not agreeing
with everything
and is it unfair sometimes absolutely
but it's not so much the way we raise
them
i'm going to raise them that is going to
be unfair is really the world and that's
the first lesson
it ain't fair out there
it's not so much because of them but
because of the society we live in
but i know if i had a 14 year old boy
and
i wanted to send them out to the corner
store i would feel pretty confident in
doing that
but for my daughter it's a different
situation and it's not our fault
it's because of society like i said i
agree right where i have to be
more careful she's very strong and
capable of you know
defending herself in a lot of ways but
at the end of the day she's not as big
as strong as a dude
yeah and i'm going to worry about that
so because of that i feel i have to be
more protective of her i agree and
defend her
i agree yes
i ain't got much else then no there's
nothing else to say he said he said what
he said he said what he said
so i don't have a son i only have
daughters
but if i had a son i don't think i would
raise him any differently
you can't talk that's cats that's kept
just listening to your accent i don't
believe you
is that wrong to say you could say it
hey man
maybe your twitter account is going to
be bad but you can say i'm just saying
man
i would never raise my child differently
[ __ ] stop lying jafar
all right let's go
you know what time it is uh the type of
scenario that you're talking about i
completely agree
so okay okay so you agree
but i think is i think this world is
dangerous for both male and female
one time i was in the eighth grade and i
guess i didn't tell my dad i was going
to city walk with my friends and i
didn't come home
till like midnight or 11 pm and the cops
were like all over my block i dialed
9-1-1 i said
my daughter's gone i know where she's at
she doesn't answer her phone if it was
my brother because he's three years
older than me so at the time i was like
14 he'd be 17 my dad would be like
whatever you know if he calls me calls
me but if it's me it's like oh my god
my daughter is missing
i don't know what's so odd about that
okay
here's what i will concede sometimes can
fathers be
slightly overprotective of their kids to
the point where it's to their detriment
rough can can mom be slightly
overprotective of their
son to their detriment sure same thing
i'm not going to disagree with that not
in the same things
but your wedding who you wed who you
bring home
yeah yeah but i think in terms of being
invasive in the person's life i think
daughters have to deal with much more
i'm not absolutely but you also have to
understand the world that we live in
you guys can't have it both ways you
can't have the eye as well movement
claim that men are
in some ways very predatory and do some
very bad stuff
and that women are majoritarian the
uh ones who suffer from those kind of
situations and then also say
well why are you treating me differently
than my brother well
because there's more risks and you've
been telling this this for so long
so of course i'm going to look at the
world differently
you guys have told me it's different for
you am i missing something
but does that mean that it's not true
that like fathers can't go they do
i agree and it's to your detriment but
also understand where it's from
you have to try to find a fine line and
i think most parents would agree they'd
like to be a little bit
too overprotective than underprotective
when the stakes were pretty high i think
he can be a little overprotective when
it comes to like having friends that are
guys
i think he assumes a lot and i think he
should just
assume the best not the worst it's his
job to assume
yeah yeah it's tough
again it's one of those lines that you
have to find i think it's easy as a
child to say assume
the best the problem is when the worst
happens
you just you're gonna feel terrible
forever straight up you know so
that's the tough thing and in the world
it's constantly inundating you with fear
of like
kids being lifted child trafficking all
this other stuff and so
it's hard i can i can even though i'm
not one myself i can i can sympathize
with what parents are dealing with at
times
my best friend is a boy we're very very
very close
and we're both in between housing
situations right now for when we go back
to college
we have this brilliant idea let's get a
place together where best friends will
hang out
24 7. my dad's not cool with it i'm just
not going to challenge it because
no reason to you're not cool with him
but you would raise him equally so your
dog
you would if you had it if you had a son
you would let him go yeah yeah no you
can't go with that girl you can't live
with that girl you'd say that to your
son
really bro why aren't you cool with it
if you don't mind me asking
because i think there's a place in the
time for everything and i don't think
that i'm ready for her to move in with
a guy that i don't know and you know
human nature is like if they're living
together
they're going to hook ups
it's not guaranteed but the odds are way
higher yeah
that is what it is you know what
proximity like yo people date who's
around them you know what they say
yeah this is like and i've seen it
happen so many times
of course roommates that go at it then
it ruins the living situation
hurt it's so many and then that then i'm
gonna have to move out get into it
it just wouldn't it would never happen
between like there's no
way ever how many girls have said that
oh he's my friend it would never happen
then he makes a shot i'm like hey
where's tim he's like we're not talking
right now
how many times how many times many
many men
wish sex upon me
[Music]
my back to the wall now you go see
you're 20 right 20 years old
say you had a 20 year old son and he was
in a living situation
where we don't have a female roommate i
think the answer is
i think the answer is obvious okay
because
as you said now i'm gonna go back to
agreeing with you that you have to treat
it a little differently but i think if i
had a son and he was 20 and he would
want to live
with a girl i wouldn't have any
objection
does not compute no no
no hold on he just admitted to say that
the other guy was right to say that
there's a little bit the difference
okay so i'mma give him that because he
admitted it yeah okay so
yeah but it does not would you find it
weird if you had a son
and he was 20 and he wanted to live with
a girl and there was nothing romantic
there at all
no i wouldn't find it weird i know how
guys are you know when they're young
they got a lot of testosterone and girls
that like to tease
it's dangerous for chicks
brian i don't think you can say that
brian i think it's a little bit too
old-school like that's a little bit too
old-school goddamn brian hey listen you
can't have pre-world war two rhetoric
okay
jesus christ i mean they gotta really
watch their step
but what if we're just sitting down and
we look good is that still teasing
someone
you can't it can be it depends on what
you're doing but i feel like girls don't
even try doing it intentional sometimes
people are just good at looking
which kind of works to this point it's
like yeah sometimes you're just good
looking and people make a move on you
sometimes it's not even your fault you
ladies sometimes don't do anything wrong
before the guy sometimes makes his move
doesn't change the fact that as a father
you might be worried about that when the
girl's a teenager
and she wants to have her best guy
friend over like you're right
sometimes you're not doing anything to
encourage the behavior but unfortunately
as a dude like
i remember being a teenager like you
just don't think rationally no
right just like a girl touches your arm
like
you know what i mean remember the first
time a girl just grabbed me like this
and like her titty was pressed against
my arm oh yeah
oh wow oh my god
things happen in your head yeah so it
doesn't mean i'm gonna just jump on her
but
if you raise them equally then they'll
learn
and grow up to see each other as equals
instead of like
having like misogyny and stuff like that
i completely agree with that
me too blaming the girls kind of puts
the onus on the girls to
stop that gross behavior when the onus
is on
the boys and the people who are raising
them and the media that they're watching
i'm inclined to agree with what she was
saying i do feel like um it puts on the
women when
dudes have to learn better
self-discipline that regard so i
definitely go through that
but it doesn't change the fact that that
risk is still out there so
you just can't afford to live in a
eutopic
idea where men are going to treat women
that way because it's just not the
reality that we live in today
bro you know i got i got a three years
and a half older sister than me
yeah so when she was 18 i was 14 and a
half
yeah going on 15. yeah she skipped the
grade so everybody when she
everybody was older than that she was
in college in the college it's not like
whenever you leave your housing
college was right there so every night
she would come back home and see what i
was like
and it was the end of semester party
right and she wanted to go she was going
with another one of her girlfriends
and when it wasn't like she was of
course like every immigrant parents you
need seven to ten business days
to tell your parents where you're going
all right
that's that's the thing so so on the
night
of both my parents and my both my
parents in their room
she goes up so yeah i'm about to go to
the party and he's like my bad is like
huh where's your brother
and me i'm like oh yeah it's about to go
down and she's like but now i don't want
to bring him look
where's your brother let me talk to your
brother and my she went to get me
like i moved out of that because i was
right next door to the
to the room i went downstairs a couple
of stairs and she wanted to see me
actually dad wants to see you and i'm
like
listen listen listen to me closely i'm
not here to put any sticks in your
wheels
i'm not here to stop you but if i'm not
going
you're not going i will not be in your
way just let me do
i go up and i go to my dad i'm like yeah
i was that what the [ __ ]
because i wasn't no cause you have to be
you know you have to be like
you're about to take the challenge you
understand what i'm saying you know what
i mean
hunger games okay i mean so i just step
up and i'm like no no no
no no hunger games first games of course
so
here's some money you're gonna go to the
party with your sister i want you back
at that time
yeah but you know usually parties yeah
so it would be that time
can i have a little bit more because
we're gonna have we're gonna have to
take uh
a cab a cab is about 25 to 30 dollars
you know yeah sure gives me that and i'm
like okay
cool and i didn't drink so i was not
about to get partied up whatever i
didn't drink at the time
i was training to go to the olympics i
wasn't i was safe it was not to turn up
it was really for the cover
and the ride back home and i'm like yo
i'm not here to [ __ ] you up
here's the money i'm not even gonna act
like i'm your brother no
take the money i tell my sister take the
money we're going
i dress up we get it we get in we first
thing i had to look like
you know i'm finishing you know
everything in front of the bouncer
bouncer lets me go
like i without even carting me and he's
like excuse me and i'm like yeah have a
nice night
yeah youtube bro get in when we
once we got inside the club i went
see you at 2 30 and i left and i was
always having
eye contact and our bond was never
stronger
since that time but of course
i had to go you've heard of
all the things that can happen if you're
not vigilant you heard of all those
things so yeah
he was just being protective and that's
just normal
what would you say is the biggest
challenge for you too
probably something like communication
and just understanding
how i feel and sometimes that i
don't agree with things that he thinks
recently
i decided i wanted to live with my mom
because
i just get a lot of intense anxiety
around him and it might be a little
awkward
i struggled to communicate my feelings
to my family
a lot of the times i just don't know how
my dad will react
to some of my feelings and i just don't
want i don't like
for him to see me upset because i know
what upsets him
a lot i do remember very vividly one
time him telling me that
whatever my energy is he's gonna
put the same energy back i remember he
told me that one time and it kind of
just
stuck with me and i always think about
it so i'm always thinking
how do what do i say how do i put myself
like
when i'm angry and stuff
i feel that i've been a very open father
and understanding
and i try to let her know that i'm not
going to judge her i'm not here to judge
her
i'm here to help her i definitely feel
that she doesn't feel comfortable
expressing herself to me fully and it's
so strange you know because
we grew up so close we grew up so close
we were together all the time
i feel like when she became a teenager
it was like all that changed
everything it's normal that like you
didn't go
through the same thing and then go
through life through the same
lens so it's possible that there are
some disparities within
the way that she sees the and on top of
that there's a gender gap then i'm
generally i'm sorry
there is a there's a gap between
you and her because of the the which you
live at the time that you live
and what she lived at a time that she
lived you know what i mean so there's a
gap there is definitely a generation gap
there so of course generation gap plus
you didn't go through life through the
same lens it's normal
that you also you know relationships ebb
and flow
there's going to be times where you guys
are very close and then there's going to
be quite a bit of distance and it comes
back together
yeah relationships are not necessarily
always going to be stagnant especially
not with family members
at periods where i didn't talk to my
fans some of my siblings for many many
years and then
now we're really close like it varies so
um
yeah that's what i would say to that it
was like alternate universe like what is
this what is going on
you just have to give her some space
definitely
i don't know i guess uh
it scares me a lot to disappoint him
that makes sense but
just know that you're never gonna
disappoint me like nothing you do will
ever disappoint me
i love you infinitely for who you are
and and i accept you fully for who you
are
i love you unconditionally okay
sorry it's okay love it's okay
yeah well you have to ruin that
yeah it's the same space she's wearing
it but if you say that and she's with
her dad
he's gonna decide if this is a space or
not what you mean is it safe space it's
okay she's shot that's where you lost me
what what place is not safe for a woman
to really cry
stop crying like who's gonna come out of
the woodwork to be like
them tears is offending me oh my god get
them about no come on bruh i just
what was it it was a great moment they
were having a connection
and you felt the need to just it's a
safe space
man shut up it's totally okay you don't
disappoint me you never will
i didn't really have my mom to run to
when i started my period like all the
girl things
literally like yeah i see my mom here
and there but my dad
took custody me at such a young age so
that made us like have a really strong
relationship he's also like my best
friend i tell him everything i tell him
who i'm dating this and that
and the cool thing is about him is like
dads could be like don't do this don't
do that
but if anything he just gives me really
good advice that's really sweet
that's a really good thing that's
actually kind of cool to hear she hides
about 20
of stuff for me and i had about 20 from
her she doesn't tell me
everything because i don't want to know
too much you know yeah because if you
tell so much you're going to be like
tease
i agree with them there's some things i
just don't want to hear about
you wonder who i banged last week no
we're not having that conversation
[Music]
we're not doing that when i was 18 i
wasn't ready to say anything to anybody
i'm a very private person and my dad is
too so he understands and he never
he never pried and he never asked too
many questions i don't know
what's up with the shadows but every
time it pants to him yeah he always
comes out looking like a disney villain
yeah
and it's unnecessary so he's he's even
has the jafar
mold yeah that's what i'm saying yo
that's what i'm saying
so that's why i'm just i'm worried for
agrabah because this man looks serious
so my grandpa died five years ago my dad
went to go
be in israel say goodbye to his dad
spend time with his family
but my dad was there for a month and we
didn't see him for that month
and i realized a couple years later that
he went so he wouldn't have to grieve in
front of us
it just made me sad that he felt like he
couldn't do that and now i understand
why
i know that i'm the backbone of the
family and i like
and i'm the only man of the house so i
wouldn't want to see myself
breaking down in front of anyone of my
family i don't think there was a
situation that i needed to
but i i wouldn't think that i'd be
comfortable opening up that much
i feel similar i feel like i have to be
strong just because i can't
show her what i'm going through because
then i kind of putting her through it
similar to what you said
it's an interesting dynamic where i
think the fathers want that from their
daughters because they feel like that's
their role but
they can't reciprocate that feeling
which uh i think it's an interesting
thing to hear from dads but i'm not
surprised no i'm not
yeah yeah not surprised but it's
refreshing to hear actually
it's good because i wanna know the thing
is i want as a dad
yeah i wanna know so i can protect you
right but you can't know because
i want you to know that i'm still strong
to protect you
right so that's the reason why there's
that dynamic and that's why
they want them to be they want the
daughters to say
so much but they're not willing to give
out so much because if you give out so
much
and you you you you dash out a little
sign of weakness then you're not so much
that person to protect you
yeah you understand so that's the reason
why for that dynamic and i understand it
you know just recently she made a big
decision
she decided that she wanted to stay with
her mom full time
since she was two years old we've always
shared custody 50 50 down the middle
so i went from seeing her half of the
time to
here and there and it hurt me hurt me a
lot it hurt me down to my core
but at the end of the day that was her
decision and she thought it was best for
her mental health
so i agreed with it but i can't sit here
and say that night i didn't go home and
cry
you know but obviously that's not
something i want her to see because
i want her to be happy regardless of
anything
i think i think this might be the best
cast they've ever had for a jubilee
video
this is amazing this is really good it's
amazing yeah mine is like the producer
being like this is the same spike
i give this a 9 out of 10. that was very
insightful it was interesting to hear
um seems like they're very reflective
both on the the daughters and the
the parents side of things so i was
really appreciative of that and uh
yeah i have mostly positive things to
say um i think about that a lot like the
kind of father i want to be in
and and um that's interesting a lot of
the stuff i didn't
want what that i said i didn't want to
do seems like mistakes that they admit
to
having made the whole idea of like
putting a tremendous amount of
expectations on the child
was one that really resonated with me um
why just because it's something i'm
grateful my mom didn't do on
me too heavily and my dad especially
didn't do
but i did see what i did to my other
siblings bro so
i think that's just interesting to hear
now who knows maybe when i'm there i
might
act differently but i think conceptually
it's just not something so
for me it reaffirmed some stuff and it
was just interesting to listen to the
thing that happened is that whenever
your parents put pressure on you
they don't see it as pressure they see
it as encouragement so what you're not
for you're never really too far from
putting pressure on someone
yeah you know what i mean what was seen
as a joke
really was something that like it always
whenever my parents said like or the
first one that becomes a doctor
we pay him a cadillac i was like
that something that they just said like
that well my dad said
if you become a doctor or a nurse i'm
gonna give you my stethoscope and my mom
had to push it a notch right
right she had to and that's why i gave
my extra extra read all about it side
you understand what i was lying yeah
so she had to put you tonight and be
like yeah i'm gonna give you a cadillac
if you become a doctor or this and that
i'm like
pressure but and i was just like i know
i gave up yeah
i just gave up on myself because
how am i going to compete with someone
that is three years ahead of three years
and a half ahead of me not only three
years and a half
she's four years ahead of me because she
skipped one year right she's five years
ahead of me because i
got left back one how
yeah sway yeah so i was just like
this is just not happening it's not
happening yeah
so yeah it gave up that was not their
goal
to to put pressure on me but sometimes
you don't realize that you put pressure
on your kids
yeah but you still do yeah
well i think uh that's pretty much all i
have for today's video pretty much we
want to hear your thoughts what do you
guys think oh [ __ ] i know what they're
thinking
i know what they thinking this beat is
jamming
[Music]